you think um
maybe uh
from your perspective you have a blind
spot
and
and i'd love for you to push back on
this one here the blind spot is
you know
the only life you've ever lived is the
life of a alpha raised by an alpha
who raised two boys who are alphas
who the way you describe your father was
a guy that pushed you guys challenged
you guys he brought you guys together to
back each other up and all you know is i
can fight i can play chess i can now
thank you i can get out of things i have
the gift of gap i can talk i can do so
that's the only lens you have where
you know if we were living in times of
biblical times a guy like you would
probably end up being the emperor a guy
like you who can do all of those things
you're probably going to make it to the
top correct but they create a loss and
orders for guys like you to not bully
the little guy to protect the little guy
that's right they came up with the gum
to call it the great equalizer where
naturally you're supposed to gravitate
to the top naturally great because of
all those things you bring to the table
people want a guy like like even in new
york many times brownsville they wanted
some of the mob there because the map
prevented girls from being taken
advantage of absolutely but they still
broke the law so there was still that
element of so do you think a part of it
where for you
yes i can a person may say i can see why
tate wants to be in a place where
there's
less
fewer law order versus in a place where
there's higher law order because it
doesn't really defend it doesn't protect
them that's a really good point of view
it actually ties in very interesting to
another point i want to make
um where there's a correlation between
people who are free thinkers and people
who have opinions which differ from the
norm and their testosterone levels i
don't even have seen this
but the higher your testosterone level
the more likely you are to stand up and
say something that the group doesn't
agree with the basic premise behind it
biologically is you're more prepared to
defend your idea if you stand up against
five men and say you're wrong i believe
this
at some point and especially in history
that can become violent so if you don't
have the capability or at least the
bravery to stand up and face the
possibility of violence you're more
likely to just comply with the group
thing so they've done a whole bunch of
studies that proves somebody who is
combative if not in a negative way but
combative as a whole in regards to not
physically afraid of having a of having
a confrontation let's say is more likely
to have an independent idea as opposed
to somebody who is the complete opposite
they're just pure group think because
fish fish swim in schools right that's
how they protect themselves so it's an
interesting point you have there and
also that can be extrapolated if you
look at the political parties of the
world or you look at the different ideas
et cetera you can usually look at
someone and kind of see
their politics sometimes you can look at
him and go yeah yeah i get it right so
there's a lot of biology is a huge part
to play with it and yeah i agree with
you
and and you're totally right my view
like every other person's view on earth
is bias
and i have a large degree of
individualism and a large degree of i
can fix this myself or i'll be okay by
myself
and that's how i was raised and it's
also my genetic makeup and you're right
i completely agree with you and i
understand that and that's why each to
their own i'm not saying everybody
should decide to go move to serbia
because you're right there's mobsters in
serbia that will take advantage of a
whole bunch of people completely but for
myself and my own personal chess board
that's how i set up life and that's why
the students who follow me and the kids
i talk to i say listen
life is extremely difficult as a man
it's very [ __ ] hard there is no way i
can tell you to win unless you're a top
tier man i can't sit here and give you a
cheat code that allows you to stay a
loser and win i can only tell you what
i've done i became extremely wealthy i
became extremely capable i became
extremely smart i developed a vast
network of individuals and nobody wants
to mess with and i set up a life that
makes me
difficult to damage that's what i did
you're saying how can i comply comply
comply comply and stay weak and stay
stupid and be safe from from tyranny and
i say to you you can't do that that's
why i teach the tenants i teach and
that's also why i think they find me so
threatening because i'm teaching people
to to do exactly that i say listen
there's no strength of mind or strength
of opinion without strength of body
first thing you do is go trade don't
care what you think look what you think
too small first thing you need to do is
go train this number one if you think
two plus two is four and i think two
plus two is five and we're gonna argue
this to the end it's gonna be five so
you better go do something new splash
but
two
the reality of earth right and and i
teach kids this reality i teach men this
reality and by even doing basic things
like teaching young men to go and strong
be strong physically which is we i'd
like to think we live in a world where
that's all seen as a good thing there
are people in the world who sit and go
wait wait wait making them physically
stronger is going to affect our ability
to change the narrative in their minds
in real time with our matrix programming
that is negative do you think there's
wisdom in
not saying everything you're thinking
about so for example you know logan's
gonna have a big following that's gonna
say
well he's wiser than you tate you know
because look at you now you got banned
and he's not you know you're smart he's
wise he knew what his limits are because
he knows at what levels
somebody is above him and he knows how
to handle that versus you
you know you can't control your thoughts
and you say whatever that's on your mind
that's what got you in trouble hence
logan is wiser than tate interesting
point and i would actually agree with
that point because
as much as people think i'm speaking my
mind trust me this is 20 of the things i
think there are limits to the world
there's times to say and there's times
not to say them however i feel a duty
that logan doesn't feel and the duties
to my children's children and i believe
certain things need to be said and it
goes beyond just trying to keep my
youtube channel i have a duty i have a
sense of duty which is he doesn't feel
he does he doesn't care he will say
anything that said and you allow anyone
to get banned he doesn't give a [ __ ] as
long as he gets to continue on his
channel please don't delete my channel i
need to be a clown on this channel
that's all he cares about i care about
the world as a whole i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care if they delete me for
everywhere i don't care if i go missing
from all of social media forever i don't
care i have money i'm fine i'll go to
the mountains i'll take my car i'll
chill i have a good life it doesn't
matter to me right we have different
objectives so yeah if my objective was
primarily number one concern keep
youtube then of course i'd talk
differently but that was never my
objective so people will argue is
smarter i would just argue he has far
less important intentions and i'll argue
that he has less moral character and
he's quicker to sell out
the a lot of the things i say i'll also
be honest a lot of things i say i really
don't think we're bannable offenses i
just think i said things that got so
popular i don't think it's the things i
said i think it's how many times they
were listened to if you enjoyed this
video and you want to watch the entire
podcast click over here and if you want
to be connected with experts influencers
such as kiyosaki tate connolly
parliamentary myself and others download
the app minect where you get a chance to
connect with these folks by the minute
you get to buy the minute or have face
times with them 15 minutes ask them any
questions you might want to have
download the admin act and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]